can we fix the social care crisis
the pandemics pushed a system on the
brink even closer to breaking point as
providers struggle with funding
this week a new uk-wide levy will see
workers paying more towards national
insurance in order to pay for social
care in england
but is it just a case of more cash
or is the system fundamentally broken
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
boris johnson made a promise to take on
the challenge of fixing social care
tonight our viewers panel from across
the country and across the world
will have their say they'll tell their
stories
joining us in the studio this week are
former first secretary of state and
chair of the all party parliamentary
group on adult social care damien greene
nadra ahmed chair of the national care
association matthew lesch head of public
policy at the institute of economic
affairs
and deputy director of policy at the
nuffield trust
natasha curry
the big question facing us all tonight
can we fix the social care crisis
nothing has changed
nothing has changed we are offering a
long-term solution for the
sustainability of social care for the
future we will fix the crisis in social
care once and for all
if you've got a hundred thousand pounds
uh we'll help you
how on earth does the prime minister
think that they can get their hands on
that kind of money without selling their
home they haven't had the guts to fix
this in all their time
the national insurance rise to help pay
for the nhs and social care is on the
way
i don't mind paying if i'm paying you
know tax and national insurance to help
others we were like oh yeah let's just
pay a bit more but maybe i don't know we
might change our minds when we're
actually having to do it i worked in
care for a long time and it is massively
undefended but equally i need to put
food on the table for my little boy
we started as ever with our viewers
panel and i'd like to talk to
isha gill who's been with us before isha
good evening
good evening
your point
so i think that the tax hike has come at
a terrible time and i think in terms of
younger people
um hiking the national insurance only
hinders our ability to get on the
housing ladder or become independent
kovid's already seriously disrupted
young people's education and livelihoods
why are we hitting them with more
hardship i do think that tax hikes can
be necessary at times and i understand
that we have to fund our nhs and our
social care services
but at this point with rising costs i
think it's the wrong thing to do i've no
issue paying taxes but presently the new
tax hike is only going to hurt the
majority of people so i'd like to ask
the panel
is raising taxes the fairest way to fix
the social health care crisis
thank you very much esha so let's begin
tonight panel with our question from
esha is raising a tax on workers the
fairest way to pay for social care
damian green
you voted for it i i did because i think
we do need more money in the system i
think that will be one of the
uncontroversial things we discussed this
evening um i've suggested in the past
raising the extra money we need um in
different ways i think we should
encourage people to take insurance out
against the possibility of having large
social care costs and one of the ways i
would do that is particularly for if you
like the older generations who've had
the benefit of rising house prices is to
take a sliver of the housing wealth
there's 1.7 trillion pounds worth of
free money free equity in houses owned
by people over the age of 65 a sliver of
that would go a long way to solving this
crisis and nobody would feel they
couldn't is that what they called the
death tax well it's it's been it's
something like that except it's not a
tax i i think what because you should
get something for something and i think
people
should be encouraged there are many ways
of doing it to take out this kind of
insurance policy you could save uh for
it throughout your working life you
could pay the premiums through your
working life or you could pay a one-off
premium as i say out of a small amount
of your housing wealth um but but that
way you would have complete peace of
mind in old age but we are actually
matthew lesch
having to pay the 1.25
on nato insurance as our employers look
i completely agree uh with your viewer i
think the national insurance rise is an
absolute disgrace you're putting a tax
on to younger working people um who
don't tend to be asset rich who are
already struggling with energy price
rises with increasing cost of food
increasing costs perpetual and then
you're taking that money and and
fundamentally that the purpose of that
money is to ensure that older people who
have houses don't have to pay some of
their own costs and their own wealth to
fund their own care and i and that's an
absolutely literally a reverse robin
hood it's taking from the poor to to
fund the the care needs of the the much
more rich and i think we need
alternative ways to fund it i also think
we have to ask ourselves is this going
to actually fix the social care crisis
right now the vast majority of this
money is going to be going on the nhs is
is the nhs really going to turn around
in a few years time and say oh actually
we don't need all this extra money go to
social care now i think what we've
effectively got is more money going into
nhs without fixing the underlying issues
in the social care system and also
putting a huge burden on younger people
who aren't necessarily the beneficiaries
okay now drama this is going to raise 12
billion and as matthew says
at the beginning it's going to go to the
nhs but the theory is at least that it's
going to come to your members in the
social care sector to help them provide
uh for
the elderly particularly um what do you
think do you agree with sure that this
is the wrong way to raise that money
well i think it's you know we've got to
look at the fact that this money has to
be raised and um the question is really
really a very good one is this the right
way and it feels like it's not
especially at this moment in time
we've got to raise it somehow but we've
also got to get rid of this notion that
it's going to go to social care
because actually it is as has been
pointed out it's going to go to the nhs
first and foremost so social care is
just being used as a front and i'll be
very surprised if we see anything like
the amounts that are being talked about
so it won't fix social care
you'll reckon that actually i mean
ministers are telling us that's what's
going to happen you're telling us that
they're lying
um i think they're being liberal with
the truth
okay
let's come back i'll come back to you in
a moment let's go back to our viewers
panel and talk to uh paul clark let's
stick paul on the national insurance
rights where are you on this
well
i'm not paying the national insurance
rise i've reduced my wages through
salary sacrifice so i'm not paying it
as far as i'm concerned the nhs is a
failed institution and no amount of
money is going to fix it so i'll have no
part in it
my two sons
i pay private health care i've got a
private pension i've got private
dentists private opticians and yet when
my children need to go to the dentist
they can't get in an nh dentist so
what's the point in it
so so you're kind of taking yourself off
grid when it comes to paying for health
and social care is that the idea
i'm not taking myself off grid because
i'm paying private health insurance
and i'm paying
um national insurance i've done 32 years
of the total 35 to get my full pension
as far as i'm concerned the government
had the money out of me and i'm not
prepared to keep paying for everybody
else all right let's talk to um
phil wills phil you're in cornwall
you've heard what uh paul's had to say
what do you what do you think
that makes sense to you um well
yes it yeah i mean my story is
um my son is uh 21 he's severely
autistic um he lived at home until he
was 11. um
and then he started to self-injure and
he he injured himself to such an extent
that his um
his life was at risk so he was
hospitalized at 11 years old and then he
was sent away to birmingham and we're in
cornwall and um he ended up staying
there for three years
in a specialist unit he's 21 now and he
never will live with us he can't because
of his injurious behavior
my son now has the care that it's i
think his human right to have
paul um
you may say this is uh an exceptional
case but actually there are many
families in that kind of situation and
that's what the system pays for
yes there are like my parents both
worked my dad started work at 14 he
finished work at 73 and he passed away
two years ago at 76 and the nhs
my mum died of terminal brain cancer
three years ago and the nhs completely
failed then with misdiagnosis and
terrible treatment and i will have no
part in supporting that yes there needs
to be
something for this gentleman's case and
my heart
really does go out to him for having
children like that and it does need to
be funded somewhere but the nhs is
broken and the way it is funded does not
work
no amount of money will fix it
paul and phil thank you so much natasha
curry you spend a lot of time thinking
about this is it ever possible to
reconcile those two points of view
well i think this is a fun the
fundamental question here is not about
cost but what sort of society do we want
what sort of system do we want to
support people as we just heard in your
last viewers story so we're not just
talking about older people who might be
able to save a lot and to own a lot of
property wealth we're talking about
working age adults younger people who
need to be supported and in a society
that i would want to live in i would
want to see that support there and i
think
we need it's clear that we need to put
more money into the social care system
it's been underfunded for over a decade
i think the fairest way to do that is a
general taxation that draws on
both income
wealth and earnings um so that we all
pay in so that we all benefit that's how
we we fund all our other public services
doesn't mean that the care itself has to
be free at the point of use but i think
we need a stable and sustained funding
solution
damon green um
when you hear a story like phil will do
you think
actually that's what it's for
but you also and we had a lot coming in
a lot of stories coming in before ahead
of this program of people who find
that they are encountering a system that
doesn't do what it's supposed to do and
wonder like paul clark whether we should
keep feeding
it money to carry on not doing what it's
supposed to do the system won't work if
he doesn't get more money but putting
more money in on its own won't be enough
i agree very much with what natasha has
just said
and we need
several you know several really big
changes the first of which is much
better integration with the nhs 20 of
people in hospital don't need to be in
hospital so they're there at some danger
to themselves hospitals are dangerous
places um
for all the obvious reasons despite the
fact that everyone is trying to cure
illnesses um and of course that's much
more expensive for everyone so a
well-run social care system would allow
as is a better integration with the
health service so that as from an
individual's point of view instead of
facing this this huge divide between nhs
free at the point of use funded out of
general taxation and suddenly a social
care system where the funding is complex
and you don't know how to find your way
around it if you had much better system
and although i'm critical of many of the
things the government has done on social
care i think the idea of integrating it
with the nhs better is is a good one
let's pursue that point let's go let's
go to our panel uh our viewers panel and
i talked to uh jane mccoyd
jane
uh you've probably just heard damon
green making the case for great
integration what do you think
i think it's a brilliant idea i've
always um
i'm a retired social worker and i
trained as a nurse
many moons ago
and um
i think it should be under one umbrella
i think it should be like it was when i
started my training
everybody all older people
were looked after by the nhs
margaret thatcher introduced a community
care act and that's when we saw the
private sector develop homes
and start underpaying their staff to
look after the
older people and people who needed
caring for
jane thank you so much nadra ahmed um
you're on one side of this divide
what do you think about this point about
integration a good idea b possible
well i think um in theory integration
sounds like a great idea but in practice
it's very difficult to understand how
this will happen
um and i think it's really interesting
because
the the comment made is that um uh you
know it was after the community care act
that the the private um providers came
in and and it it's caused that issue the
reason we came out
um of local authority funding was
because it was far too expensive they
couldn't manage to run their services on
what they were they were being funded
and and the independent sector showed
that they could be innovative and cut
the costs and that's why where it went
however it hasn't been funded properly
now integration itself i'd love to know
what we actually mean by integration
because will that mean that social care
just gets subsumed
and that there is nothing because at the
moment social care is just being ignored
we are probably going to come back to
ask that question a little later
this is the great debate up next we're
asking do care workers get the
recognition they deserve
social caries is in a terrible model in
the uk we've got a social care sector
that's just too fragile we want safety
i'll visit the government on the council
to come and walk with me on a 12-hour
shift one day starting at 8 o'clock
finishing 8 30 and then we see how we
work is recruitment is holding us back
resource needs to be put behind the
drive to recruit people into care and
professionalise the the job
[Applause]
there's a lot of road between here and
the and the future of will smith he's a
major star and a major talent and it was
an unfortunate uh gaffe in his life and
career
but there's a lot of damage control to
do but uh they clearly you know saw that
this was an option with very little
downside by the way variety is reporting
as others are that he can still vote uh
he can still uh compete for oscars uh
basically he took himself out of the
line of fire
in a town uh ruled by fear and everyone
you know having handlers telling them
what to say a lot of people are very
frank and outspoken uh jim carrey has
been very outspoken about this uh bill
maher not surprisingly the american
comic denzel washington this weekend was
with a
a pastor a um a religious figure named
t.d jakes and talked about what will
smith referred to and and saw this
through a religious prism that this was
uh you know a spiritual moment um not
for the good of course i i actually
think that will uh has an opportunity to
volunteer for um working with troubled
youth doing volunteer work counseling i
think they're going to
grapple with this in a very serious way
he already has
taken full responsibility and taken this
very seriously he's not being glib about
it at all
so i think continuing down that path of
taking this very seriously trying to
understand them
provide some context for why and how
this might have happened but uh it
definitely punctures an image of a guy
who
i think is extremely beloved and a
terrific a terrific talent you know he's
an amazing major guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking can we fix the
social care crisis
thousands of elderly and disabled adults
aren't receiving the care they need
because of a shortage of workers low pay
zero hours contracts unpaid working time
among the reasons for staff quitting
their jobs
and now there are concerns that the
money raised by a rise in national
insurance contributions won't be enough
to bring them back
let's start again with our viewers panel
and talk to jan swaby good evening jan
good to see you i've just recently
started to need help with my father and
initially i found it very hard to get
any information or any idea of what help
was actually available
i believe that kovid did actually make
things more difficult as i wasn't
allowed into hospital with him
and i had a very stressful time trying
to sort out power of attorney to get
people to talk to me but even with that
i still sometimes get left out of the
loop
i think that those working in social
care are overworked and underpaid and
they don't have the time to hand hold
and help people through a process that's
new and can be very confusing during a
stressful period for the person
requiring help and their family
we've now found some of the help we need
for which i'm very grateful as i don't
think we could cope very well without it
but my question for the panel is how can
we encourage more people to become
social carers
thank you so much jen so jen
asking really about the bureaucracy of
the system but underneath that her
question
how can we encourage more people to
become
care workers
i imagine nandra that is a question that
you ask yourself every night before you
go to bed and every morning when you get
up absolutely it's keeping a lot of
providers awake at night because the
shortage of um our workforce we've got
112 000 vacancies at any given time
what's the total workforce
it's 1.5 just
just over 1.5 million so we need to
boost the workforce by about
another five well yes and we need 500
000 more if we're going to go if you
look at the demographics and i think
what's what's really important to
recognize here is that as we go forward
we look at
why are people not joining the social
care sector and and the reasons given
are quite quite often like the ones
expressed there the low pay the under
value has really come up much more than
ever before care workers feel completely
undervalued some of the things like
policy to you know for mandatory
vaccinations all of these things when it
affected social care
not the nhs all of those things make
people feel that they're being blamed
and they're you know that they're not in
the right place pays obviously a a
reason and for that i i would just say
to you that
um
the average fee for a care home
um in the small to medium-sized provider
sector that i represent
is around 600 pounds a week so we're
looking at about four
four pounds an hour-ish and that's what
providers have to do to supply and on
top of that we must also recognize that
the people we now look after
used to be looked after in long-term
geriatric um
awards
so if somebody's in in a hospital
setting
it costs over about 2 000 pounds a week
for them to be cared for in a hospital
in a care setting we think as a nation
it's okay to pay 600 pounds and less
we've got as low as 480 88
pounds a week
so your your issues about the care work
is not just money i mean obviously
there's a last point you made it's not
just the wages for care workers but
actually a sense of regard and
absolutely status all right let's let's
talk to uh panel and talk to chris
roberts who i think has a view on this
issue good evening chris uh
what have you got to say
um well my my wife has been a senior
career person in a private nursing home
for many years
and i've sat and
watched
how it all works
social care in a home setting is a
cinderella in my opinion of the nhs
generally we we've always we never we
never think about it it's always the nhs
the nhs this that and the other but when
you think about it we're all going to
grow old probably me sooner than you
we're all going to need
social care in our old age
now the lady who's just spoken on your
panel she's quite right
money is a big issue
but the image
and the
professionalism isn't there within the
cursed sector
the cursed sector is almost seen as
servitude within the industry
it's not a profession to be proud of
like a nurse like a doctor like a
surgeon
that they're almost scared they're seen
as as
you know
low low
sort of
thank you thank you chris uh matthew
lesh
this is an interesting point isn't it
it's not just money
it's can you are we proud of these
people
yes they have status it is absolutely
about status and i think
what people a lot of people get from
their job beyond the salary is that
sense of satisfaction i think there's a
lot of that in social care naturally the
fact you're taking care of somebody in
fact you're helping somebody and that
attracts a lot of people to it but at
the same time um we've got this
underlying issue across the whole
economy in fact we have an aging
population if there are people who want
to work in this country and want to work
in the care system we shouldn't be
turning them away um because of an
overly restrictive immigration system if
we need those people to come and help
take care of the elderly we should let
them in
natasha
this is quite a big issue isn't it that
the sector depends
um essentially on importing people from
abroad who
are
relatively speaking happy with lower pay
than uh people
here would
be well i think historically yes we have
had a high proportion of people coming
from overseas who have worked in the
care sector and offered enormous value
in the care that they've been able to
give what we've seen since brexit has
changed the immigration
process is that we've seen a drop off in
people entering the system from abroad
and the government has now introduced a
new visa system for social care but it's
very costly for providers and quite
complex for providers to recruit from
abroad so i think we need we need a more
joined up approach to
um immigration that that helps providers
to to bring people in um from abroad who
want to come and work it but we also
need to think about the domestic
workforce as well we need to
fundamentally we need to make this a
valued respected profession part of that
is about pay but it's also about how
those people are valued in society i
think there were some examples during
covid where nhs workers got you know
priority shopping hours social care
workers didn't for example
and i think we need to we need to change
the perception of work alongside pay and
training
so we have to send some of the right
signals about
about esteem if i can put it that way
let's come back to our viewers panel
helen phillips um
hi trevor hi i mean i've recently hi
i've recently left working for social
care for 13 years and that's because the
system literally that amount of time
hasn't worked there's been more cutbacks
more cutbacks and phil phillip with a
disabled obviously 21 year old i've
worked in disability and you know he's
in devon the family in birmingham it's a
long way for that family to travel to
even see their young person there's no
money there's no they
the care act states that they will
provide a personal sense of approach for
the individual well they don't because
if they did we'd be able to meet the
needs of those people locally in their
own community and to support family so
for me the adult social care system has
broken down which then breaks down
workers it breaks down the family
relationships the individuals
relationships is a massive impact you
know
overall it's not just around adult
social care but they definitely need
more money but they definitely need more
people trained and that's in the thing
you go into the system and it's like oh
yeah we'll give you one day induction
here's a bit of paper off you go
and you know so again we're failing to
me we fail so many families elderly
young
okay it's yeah it needs definitely needs
a revamp thank you helen damon green
i mean we're hearing a story about the
need for greater status for workers but
of course
some professions or some
areas of work have been for example
turned into all graduate professions and
that of course changes them is that what
we need here what can we do about that
no i think we absolutely need need
higher esteem i i think there are some
sort of unchallenged assumptions that
we've had the last few minutes i my
father spent the last couple of years of
his life in in care homes and so i can't
begin to say how much i admired the
workers almost all of whom weren't from
this country most of them were polish in
in the care home uh he died in and they
were completely brilliant
but let's be clear the reason to bring
a lot of people from overseas into the
sector as in any sector is to keep wages
down that's that's the effect of it i
mean whether it's the original personnel
that's the effect of it so apart from
increasing wages now
the other thing we need to do as
everyone has said
is is to basically get parity of esteem
with the health service that if you're a
nurse in a social care setting you're
likely to be paid less than a nurse
doing a very similar job in a hospital
and you also the public is not going to
be going out there on a thursday night
clapping for you so that's the big thing
that we've got to change very very very
briefly i can see not now you're looking
a little bit skeptical about this well i
mean i think all i would all i would say
is that we've got these visas um that
was announced on um christmas eve that
we could bring people in from abroad to
to look at the issues of um unemployment
and the the the salary set by the home
office um was 10 pounds something an
hour um and yet we think it's okay to
pay our domestic workforce nine pound
fifty why don't we just raise that why
don't we raise it so that we can get our
domestic workforce in all right
coming up after the break we'll be
hearing from dutch nurse josh the block
about how he transformed home care in
the netherlands
[Applause]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the great debate and we're
asking can we fix the social care crisis
it's certainly not just us grappling
with that question countries around the
world are looking for solutions when it
comes to caring for aging populations
well one company in the netherlands may
have an answer
bertsog is a brand new model of social
care that allows vulnerable people to
live independently and here to explain
what it means is its founder and chief
executive
jos the block good evening um
i wonder if you could just tell us first
of all make sure that to how first how
to pronounce burst org and explain what
it is please
yeah
is an organization where um care workers
and nurses are working in
self-organized teams
and supporting people in their quality
of life and self-support
but also focusing on the neighborhood
so they mobilize people around the
patient
so that informal care and care and
healthcare social care are working very
effectively together
if i understand it properly then
these
groups these teams of nurses and staff
maybe about a dozen work pretty much
autonomously they work independently
without much central direction and if i
if i've got the numbers right um i think
you had there were some studies about
that showed that you cut down both
bureaucracy and cost
yes
as we we can show throughout the years
we are now existing for 15 years
in holland
and we showed that by
focusing on on the results someone the
outcome for the for the patients
that we could
reduce the cost with 40 percent
um and for example for the social for
the care workers themselves we raise the
salaries
so the the price per hour uh became a
little bit higher
but the cost per patient reduced
so i think it's good to uh to focus on
um how can we on one hand
have the economical um results in in a
in a positive way and on the other hand
how can we uh create a job which is
attractive
for cab workers and is doing the right
things for the patient
so this is interesting higher salaries
more status more job satisfaction for
workers
less time
spent on the patient and the whole
system costs less
what's not to like
why has it not
transferred for example to our country
i think a lot of people
in many countries are
looking at at healthcare from a course
perspective
and
what i what i see is that this this
perspective is really bothering uh and
it's not helping
and so if you if you try to look at
social care from and
more
perspective of
how what can it contribute to humans
and how can we do it in a way that it's
as effective as possible and how can we
organize it so that we have as less as
possible bureaucracy
then you will have another
yeah you have another perspective but
what i see is new public management but
is controlling us all over the world
and is lacking
these kind of visions and these kind of
perspectives
just block thank you so much for your um
for talking to us uh i think we could
probably learn a great deal from this
thank you so much
thank you let's go back to our viewers
panel and um i think uh
we're gonna talk to jackie skip in rugby
jackie
hi trevor um i've worked for the nhs and
i've also worked for the social work
team
and i would like to see the nhs and
social care going back up together again
for lots of reasons um
i think it would promote better
communication it would be more joined at
working
um it would prevent duplication of some
tasks and some
some areas while other tasks you know
other things are falling through the
gaps between the two departments and my
question to the panel is
what can england learn from other
countries systems
thank you very much indeed jackie um
jackie's question what can england learn
from other countries social care
systems bearing in mind that uh wales
and scotland are very similar to us
they're not exactly the same because
they're devolved
natasha well i think we can learn a huge
amount from other countries and indeed
in much of my work i have been looking
internationally to see what we can learn
i think one of the things i've observed
when we've looked at systems such as the
netherlands germany and japan is that
the debate doesn't start with how much
does it will it cost and who pays but as
joss was saying what are the outcomes we
want what do we want people to be able
to achieve
supported by this system and i think
there's a different framing that we can
really learn from i also think in many
of these countries they've gone for very
clear systems easily understood they've
gone for very consistent
needs assessments for example so in
germany or japan it doesn't matter where
you live or how old you are what your
what your conditions are you go through
the same needs assessment process and i
think one of the issues in the english
system is that it's very variable in
terms of what you can access
so i think there are many many things we
can learn and we can also learn from our
nearest neighbours as you say
the other nations of the uk are devolved
and they have taken slightly different
directions with their social care
systems
um all of them are undergoing reform
at the moment so i think we can learn a
huge amount from their experiences as
well all right let's um let's talk about
countries which
perhaps aren't exactly
uh like this country rose malenga buckle
you've got
experience in africa
yes um thank you trevor
i'm a careful manager
i immigrated from zambia
19 years ago
and um in zambia
we don't have a chassis system like we
do in england
and those that are elderly
have to be looked after by their own
family or their own children now
if you are poor
then you are left to your own devices
you don't have anybody to look after you
a lot of british people don't appreciate
what they have matthew this is a
a pretty fundamental point isn't it for
large parts of the world actually
we talk about an elaborate system here
but in most parts of the world it's the
family particularly the women in the
family that's it
and that's obviously the way
historically we provided care to people
i think we have to be a little bit
careful about assuming we can learn a
lot from other contacts and sometimes
there are things to learn but also
different contexts have different
cultural
norms about for example where people
live in the uk uh people often don't
live anywhere near um their elderly
relatives because people move around the
country a lot more as a result of that
it's much harder to see a system in
which people just take care of their own
parents or their own their own
grandparents um can you take the system
in holland and um maybe that works very
well in theory but can that actually be
implemented in practice right across the
country um across lots of different
council areas i'm not certain maybe it
can maybe it is a great idea we just
have to be i think a little bit
skeptical when it comes to what might
sound great in theory might be very hard
to copy and implement in practice in the
uk oh
yes no can i just come back to that and
i entirely agree context really matters
and with social care it's so important
that it's embedded in social cultural
values of our country
i think what we can learn from other
countries is their approaches and the
principles on which they've built
sustainable and effective systems so i
don't agree with you know dragging and
dropping
the same system but i do think we can
learn a lot about approaches and
principles that they've followed i want
to talk to ed solman because uh let's
bear in mind um wales is a different
country to england um and i think your
experience may be a little different
from what we've been hearing so far
yes i travel yes certainly i mean
in 2013 i had an amputation due to glass
in my um in my leg in wales um the
aftercare is brilliant we get um
free equipment free wheelchairs
uh worth six thousand pound um equipment
is fantastic i'm not sure exactly the
price in england
um what the situation's like but in
wales
it's brilliant and the care i get is
fantastic as well you know the care i've
had since
2000
2013
is um has just been brilliant and um i
never went into hospital until i turned
40 and now i spent the whole of my 40s
in hospital
ed thank you so much uh damian green
maybe we should all move to wales
oh i mean i'm delighted ed's had had
that experience after a terrible
accident but we heard somebody early on
saying he wasn't going to pay for the
nhs
because
he'd had a very bad experience of it so
people's personal experience of course
color this but i thought the um
the our dutch guest
said something
underneath uh that was really
interesting which was that he
experimented uh in a way
that
allowed as as we heard a sort of better
and cheaper system it was it was what's
not to like as you said and i think the
the danger in this country particularly
at the extremely seductive argument of
let's put it all under the nhs and it
will be free and it will be wonderful
that itself is a a questionable
proposition but but even more i think
what that would certainly do is reduce
the amount of experimentation
and if you like social entrepreneurship
that they've had in holland which seems
to work and and that's one of the things
i really think we should learn from
abroad that in other
countries and other cultures it's easier
for people to have good local ideas and
say let's try them and and too much of
our both health and social care in this
country is actually stifled by a lot of
bureaucracy so you can't have good ideas
and experiment with them in one area and
say hey maybe we could try this across
the country all right thank you
you're watching the great debate after
the break
we'll be asking a more fundamental
question should people lean on the state
for support for their families
health
and social care
it begins at home
people do decide not to come to shaker
homes because of cost why should i
have to sell my home
to have continuing care before dementia
i didn't realize how unjust it was
[Applause]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
power
people
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment
that she was going to sit down with me i
might be just very naive but i do
believe that change is possible
otherwise we wouldn't be climate
activists
[Music]
i'm conference for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these these sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating i think everything's at
stake the future of our planet the
future of this beauty around us
the future
of you and me
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russian
soldiers air raid sirens fill the
airways in the distance artillery rains
down it feels very close to the center
of
there's one
they found this devastation to their
apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
[Applause]
can we fix the social care crisis that's
the topic of the great debate this week
and i'm going to go straight to our
viewers panel
and talk to jubeir
khan zubair good evening
good evening travis
you've got a question for our panel i
think
yeah who should be responsible for
carrying the most vulnerable people in
society
and who what do you think the
alternatives are here
well i believe this social care needs to
be fixed
uh
as a matter of urgency for our aging
population and it should be free at the
point of delivery for those that need it
and like the nhs and you must not be
means tested
okay all right so bear thank you so much
the first question for a panel
who should be responsible for caring for
the most vulnerable people in society a
question we touched on last part matthew
i mean what we're effectively talking
about there if you make it like the nhs
entirely state funded is nationalizing
the entire system i'd just like to know
where that money comes from we've
already got huge underfunding issues in
social care if we take out any
contribution from people who can't
afford to pay you're going to just
exacerbate those issues and this is the
problem with social care it's always not
going to have enough money the
government has too many priorities uh we
we have obviously the healthcare system
we have education we have more demands
in the context of international security
for military funding they have
international aid the list goes on and
on so the question then here and i think
we need to make we need to do a really
important distinction here on the one
hand you have people who are
particularly young adults who require
social care who haven't had the
opportunity um to earn income in their
lives and of course um the state has to
step in to provide that care and and
that has to be taxpayer funded now you
can afford to do that if at the same
time you say to people who are elderly
who have assets who can afford to pay
that they should make a substantial
contribution to their own care so the
people who can pay should pay the people
who can't should have that subsidized
the problem what the government's
recently announced is it's not quite
that they're asking they're subsidizing
people who could afford to pay all right
okay
let's come back to mark dabs um on our
viewers panel mark where do you stand on
this
question of how we divide the
responsibility and if you like the
burden i think people sometimes call it
between
home family
and state
good evening uh yeah well i've worked in
the health service for 35 years you know
in nhs and
home care
and social services and i think that you
know the conclusion i've come to is that
we should have some kind of private or
insurance system let's go to rachel
dambrosio
rachel um do you agree with that that uh
we as individuals should be bearing more
of the responsibility here
i definitely think that we all should be
responsible
and and obviously
putting it through taxes is probably the
only way to do it and to make it more
responsible for everybody and well i
think we're so lucky to live in a
country where we have this wonderful
system where everybody puts into the
same pot and we can help everybody in
need i have a daughter who is 22 and has
cerebral palsy and she didn't ask to be
disabled she didn't choose to be
disabled and as much as there are
problems in the nhs and in social care
if we didn't have that as a family i
don't know how what kind of a life she
would actually have if if we had to rely
totally on family to provide that care
see at the moment i provide over 50
hours of care a week for her which i'm
very happy to do but i do appreciate
that as the years go on and i get older
i'm not going to be able to do that
thank you so much so much rachel um now
we seem to be coming down to a pretty
straightforward choice here that we need
to move in the direction of spreading
the load as it were in the way that we
do
in theory at least
with the nhs but there's some doubts
about whether that actually works in
practice whether we get a good enough
service
well i think what we've also got to
remember is that when social care came
in into being
it was always means tested but the
people that were being looked after were
not with the complex healthcare needs
that they have now so we've moved the
goal post to social care taking on very
complex health care needs and so the
funding of it becomes much more
challenging because of course the
funding didn't follow so as hospitals
started to keep you know less of the
complex cases there we've got them we've
got end of life care we've got all of
that so the funding hasn't followed and
that's where we sit
who's responsible i think is really
interesting
something that sticks in my mind from
years ago when i met somebody who said
um and i was saying what a great job he
was doing with his wife and he said in
trying to make her independent
i've lost mine
and that was really profound for me
because
looking after his wife at home meant he
lost david damon green um
we're gonna run into a crunch here
somewhere aren't we i mean we have to
somehow
disentangle the question of who pays
how we get enough money
and actually whether we
can find ways of improving the syst the
quality of delivery of the system
what is the next step here i mean there
isn't a single answer obviously but
what's the next step i i mean i think
first of all i think it's a false choice
to say either it's the individual's
responsibility or it's the state's
responsibility it's a bit of both uh
have we got the balance right now it's
really the question and i think um for
those who can afford it
uh they should be encouraged to
insurance systems i completely agree
with what mark said
to to pay that way or to pay some of it
that way obviously for people who can't
afford it and that will be a significant
chunk of the population it should be
funded out of taxation but we're hitting
the limits of the taxation that people
are willing to pay and i suspect those
limits will will get really stretched
this year so there are a whole raft of
things that we haven't discussed yet
that that we need
uh to do as well as get more money into
the system one of which is to build
housing that people can live in
comfortably even as they get older and
frailer we build about a tenth as much
a proper supported housing in this
country as they do in america or
australia or new zealand now that will
mean that if if people are very severely
ill or have dementia need that sort of
level of care provided in care homes of
course they'll get that at the end of
their lives but the more people who can
live in their own homes for longer is
not only cheaper for the system but much
more importantly it's what people want
it gives them a better quality of life
we should aim at that
i doubt this is the last time that we
talk about this topic on this show but
that's all we have time for this evening
just remains for me to thank our
panelists here in studio natasha curry
matthew lesh naja ahmed and damian green
of course it's you at home who are the
center of this conversation and if you'd
like to be part of the program next time
you can get in touch by emailing the
great debate at sky dot uk
for now i just want to thank
our wall viewers panel as ever thank you
for your questions and for your thoughts
and of course for you at home keep
talking we'll see you again at the same
time next week for the great debate